[Music]
let's take a step back this is
manifestly not saigon the fact of the
matter is this
we went to afghanistan 20 years ago with
one mission in mind and that was to deal
with the people who attacked us on 9 11
and that mission has been successful we
brought bin laden to justice a decade
ago
al qaeda the group that attacked us has
been vastly diminished its capacity to
attack us again from afghanistan
has been
right now does not exist and we're going
to make sure that we keep in place uh in
the region
the capacity the forces necessary to see
any re-emergence of a terrorist threat
and to be able to deal with it so in
terms of what we set out to do in
afghanistan
we've done it
[Music]
all eyes will be on linda thomas
greenfield the us representative of the
security council trying to explain the
us's position right now and what the us
is going to do
after what nearly every diplomat i've
spoken to says is a catastrophic foreign
policy failure by washington
[Music]
you